[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 18 mars
ça c'est la troisième vague c'est ce
département tombe sous la coupe d'un
nouveau confinement ont décrété pour
quatre semaines en ile de france dans
les hauts de france l'eure la seine
maritime et les alpes maritimes à
compter de vendredi minuit dans le reste
du territoire le couvre-feu décalé à 19h
côté vaccins reprise demain après-midi
de l'astra zeneca après le feu vert du
régulateur européen l'escaladent entre
vladimir poutine et joe biden le premier
propose au deuxième une discussion
diffusé en direct vendredi ou lundi le
président russe qui un peu plus tôt
affirmé déjà je cite que nous voyons
toujours au rang l'autre nos propres
caractéristiques et qu'il défendra les
intérêts russes le président américain
de son côté dit ce soir ne pas regretter
d'avoir qualifié poutine de tueurs
washington appelle les entités
impliquées dans nord stream ii à se
désengager immédiatement sous peine de
sanctions
[Musique]
dans ce contexte de tension une
délégation américaine est à moscou
aujourd'hui pour participer à une
conférence sur la paix en afghanistan
une réunion en présence des négociateurs
talibans et des représentants du pouvoir
afghan est ce matin kaboul a été le
théâtre d'un attentat le deuxième cette
semaine
bilan provisoire au moins quatre morts
et neuf blessés
[Musique]
conférence de presse de jean castex et
d'olivier vers an alors que la
progression de l'épidémie s'accélère
nettement la vie de certains français à
nouveau chambouler
pour plus de précisions nous retrouvons
tout de suite en direct au mas bonne et
de l'avenue de ségur bonsoir thomas que
retenir de cette conférence du premier
ministre jean castex et du ministre de
la santé olivier verrons après des jours
de tractations c'est donc le retour de
l'attestation en journée un confinement
7 jours sur 7 décrété dans seize
départements les départements qui
forment les régions île de france et
haute france ainsi que l'eure la seine
maritime et les alpes-maritimes dans ces
départements à partir de vendredi soir
minuit et pour une durée de quatre
semaines au moins les écoles resteront
ouvertes mais seuls les commerces qui
vendent des biens de première nécessité
pourront également restés ouverts il
sera possible de sortir de chez soi dans
un périmètre de 10 km autour de son
domicile avec donc la présentation de
cette fameuse attestation les
déplacements inter régionaux seront
interdits et puis le couvre-feu passera
de 18 à 19 heures jean castex qui a
présenté également un plan pour le
télétravail il encourage les français à
pratiquer le télétravail au moins quatre
jours par semaine c'est un lieu où il ya
beaucoup de contamination sur le lieu de
travail justement je propose d'écouter
le premier ministre lors de cette
conférence de presse
nous devons également être très vigilant
sur les risques de contamination sur les
lieux de travail
la dernière étude réalisée par
l'institut pasteur montre que ces lieux
représente 29 % des cas identifiés cela
plaide pour que dans les prochaines
semaines toutes les entreprises toutes
les administrations qui le peuvent
pousse au maximum le télétravail tout en
maintenant toujours une journée sur
place pour les salariés qui le
souhaitent au moins quatre jours sur
cinq en télétravail c'est l'objectif
qu'il faut atteindre et reconnaissant le
beaucoup d'entreprises en sont encore
loin aujourd'hui thomas de nouvelles
mesures de restriction qui s'accompagne
aussi de la reprise de la campagne de
vaccination avec le sérum d'astrazeneca
oui et d'ailleurs la conférence de
presse avait été repoussé d'une heure
justement pour avoir toutes les
informations concernant les conclusions
rendues aujourd'hui par l' agence
européenne du médicament concernant donc
ce vaccin astrazeneca des conclusions
qui font état d'un vaccin sûr et
efficace et jean castex a donc tenté de
rassurer tout au long de sa prise de
parole ce soir en expliquant que la
campagne de vaccination avec ses doses
d'astrazeneca reprendra dès demain
après-midi et d'ailleurs pour illustrer
cette reprise
le premier ministre se fera vacciner lui
même ce sera donc demain après midi en
région parisienne jean castex qui
recevra une dose d'astrazeneca
merci thomas bonnet en direct de
l'avenue de ségur et le pays donc face à
la troisième vague et de nouvelles
mesures annoncées pour freiner la
propagation du virus des millions de
français des dizaines de millions en
nouveaux confiné un peu plus
d'un an par jour pour jour après la
première mise sous cloche alors va-t-on
vraiment sortir de cette crise place à
notre décryptage ce soit et pour en
débattre nous sommes avec yves blein un
député la république en marche 14e
circonscription du rhône bruno m'égare
ban médecin chef du service réanimation
à l'hôpital lariboisière à paris
enfin alexis poulain éditorialistes
bonsoir à tous les trois merci d'avoir
accepté l'invitation pour réagir donc à
ces nouvelles mesures alors c'est une
troisième voie que nous retenons une
voie qui doit permettre on a envie de
dire enfin de freiner sans enfermer le
médecin que vous êtes bruno mais
gardanne et satisfait ce soir par ces
mesures du premier ministre alors on
peut pas dire que je suis satisfait ou
pas en fait
la progression de l'épidémie s'est
accélérée depuis quelques jours avec une
augmentation du nombre de cas qui
arrivent dans les hôpitaux
malheureusement comme vous le savez le
capacitaire des services de réanimation
et extrêmement limités et donc désormais
nous étions face à la menace de ne pas
pouvoir faire face à l'arrivée de ces
patients de devoir trier
car effectivement les transferts sont
désormais extrêmement difficile et les
lits disponibles extrêmement rare donc
de fait effectivement c'est une mesure
de sauvegarde qui a été prise alors
c'est une troisième voie entre le
confinement strict version mars avril où
on avait donné l'ordre de ne pas sortir
de chez soi
malheureusement une telle mesure
n'aurait pas été acceptée par la
population et finalement des mesures
plus laxiste qui consigne qui
consisterait à laisser faire les choses
qui probablement aurait abouti également
un échec
c'est malheureusement le manque de choix
il faut savoir que ces mesures de
restriction des libertés publiques sont
prises aujourd'hui pour compenser le
nombre de lits qui manque en réanimation
nous payons la facture d'une stratégie
de santé publics déficiente depuis
plusieurs années avec pour seul objectif
une un contrôle comptable des choix et
malheureusement une réduction du nombre
de lits et une réduction du personnel
soignant qui fait défaut aujourd'hui
e yves blein on entend le docteur
évidemment on comprend aisément tous ses
arbitrages compliqué surtout pour le
corps médical qui vit évidemment des
journées éprouvantes mais enfin un an
après toujours le manque de lits le
manque de vaccins on en parlera tout à
l'heure et on en est là art confiné un
an après et d'ailleurs on en parlera
aussi tout à l'heure à ne pas savoir une
heure avant à quelle sauce on va être
mangé c'est quand même un constat
d'échec pour le gouvernement qui a peiné
d'ailleurs à l'admettre il veut blain je
sais pas si vous nous entendez la
liaison en voilà eh bien j'espère si
vous avez entendu mais ma question
alors là non après on en est là
effectivement le docteur nous expliquer
voilà le le manque de lits et on
comprend bien l'urgence des hôpitaux le
cri d alerte des médecins puisque
l'épidémie progresse de plus en plus
dans ces régions concernées mais tout de
même on en est là on n'aurait pas pu
faire autrement ce n'est pas un constat
d'échec de la part du gouvernement un
monsieur castex on est défendue mais
mais tout de même c'est un petit peu le
sentiment qu'ont de nombreux français se
soient servis lassitude y est celle du
gouvernement du ministre de lier ces
deux d'une démarche pragmatique qui fait
que ce virus évoluent il est barré lyon
ii les gardiens qui ont des echets 2
qu'il n'était pas les effets de la
première version puisqu'on constate
aujourd'hui par exemple que on a des
malades qui sont plus jeunes qui sont
malades plus longtemps
et des fois même plus gravement donc on
est face à une situation qu'on tente les
pollutions et en maintenant une certaine
façon de laquelle il faut s'adapter
regard notamment des stratégies peuvent
varier
il ya l'autre selon la gravité des mba
la démarche qui est du gouvernement ne
s'est pas trompé voilà qualifié d'échec
ou de réussite et puis à la limite peu
importe c'est comment on s'adapte en
permanence
une situation qui est évolutive en
fonction de ce que l'on connaît disent
qu'on peut anticiper de ces évolutions
mais aussi en fonction des shows des
capacités de soins alors on s'adapte
et effectivement jusqu'au dernier moment
alexis poulain vous êtes observateurs de
la chose politique le suspense jusqu'au
bout et à 17 heures manifestement il
était indiqué sur plusieurs scènes de
nos chaînes d'information que le
président n'avait toujours pas tranché
on navigue à vue encore et toujours
oui on est enfin quand même cet exercice
d'autosatisfaction qui est cette
conférence de presse hebdomadaire du
premier ministre sonne faux elle est
assez assez cruel à regarder d'autant
plus qu'on ne peut pas se féliciter
d'approché bientôt les cent mille morts
on ne peut pas solliciter d'utiliser
encore des mesures de confinement on ne
peut pas se féliciter de ne pas avoir
mis en place des mesures préventives ou
de regarder devant
quand les partenaires européens le
faisait en début d'année donc finalement
alors selon jean castex il n'aurait pas
fallu qu'on finit en début d'année
c'était très bien de ne pas l'avoir fait
parce que sinon c'était trois mois de
confinement on se retrouve à confiner
après les autres en avril vous avez des
pays qui commence à passer à autre chose
on a l'impression que la france est
restée bloquée en mars 2020 alors vous
pouvez aussi retour d applaudir sur
votre balcon
les soignants qui sont en berne a qui
continuent de faire tout ce qu'ils
peuvent avec le peu de moyens
olivier ferrand qui en août 2020 quand
même annoncé qu on pouvait monter les
capacités de l'hydre animations jusqu'à
douze mille lits là on en est bien
péniblement à 4000 et ça y est c'est
déjà trop pour l'urgence sanitaire et on
refait ses trains
on va bouger des malades à grands frais
plutôt que d'avoir préparé d'avoir pris
ces mois finalement de connaissance du
virus de connaissances aussi des gestes
médicaux pour aider les soignants pour
aider l'hôpital public pour faire en
sorte qu'on ait une stratégie sanitaire
tout ce qui ressort finalement ce soir
c'est l'absence de stratégie pourtant le
gouvernement paye des cabinets de
conseil comme acquise est des fortunes
pour mettre en place sa stratégie
vaccinale et autres et on se rend compte
que tout patauge
tout est dans la précipitation alors ça
va être la faute d'astrazeneca parce
qu'on n'a pas assez de doses c'était
déjà le discours d'olivier ferrand mardi
devant le sénat
la campagne de vaccination reprend
puisque l'agencé européenne du
médicament a dit qu'il n'y avait pas de
risque particulier même si des
chercheurs suédois ont bien fait la
corrélation entre les thromboses
veineuses et la vaccination
eh bien à voir si le mal n'est pas fait
dans l'opinion si les français ne vont
pas rechigné à se faire vacciner avec
astrazeneca après cette valse hésitation
et on voit bien que tout est à l'envi
les mesures de ce soir je vais tout le
monde au défi de les résumer en quelques
mots et de dire qu'il a compris et que
c'est clair c'est ce département
surveillance ont passé à 19 heures et
puis on ne sait plus alors on va
retrouver avec une joie non dissimulée
ces autos attestation de sortie qui
avait disparu pour pouvoir sortir à plus
de dix kilomètres de chez soi
alors c'est plus un kilomètre c'est plus
20 km c'est 10 et puis on va pouvoir
être confiné mais profiter quand même du
plein air c'est une bonne nouvelle mais
ça reste que la france est un pays
embourbé dans cette crise sanitaire
depuis depuis un an avec ce surplace de
d'absence de stratégie qui ne qui ne
mérite aucun bravo aucun droit seulement
une désolation et je crois que il ne
faut pas sous-estimer la fatigue et le
ras le bol des français actuellement
devant autant d'incapacité bruno mes
gars ben justement sur ces nouvelles
dispositions c'est vrai qu'on a dû peine
à peine à suivre au fur et mesure
d'aider confinement là on peut profiter
du plein air bon c'est une bonne chose
les écoles sont ouvertes tant mieux pour
les parents peut-être un peu moins pour
les malades puisque apparemment ce
variant anglais est très contagieux est
ce qu'au moins ça va être efficace cette
fois ci parce que mine de rien on laisse
les écoles ouvertes
est-ce qu'il fallait y aller encore plus
franchement est-ce que vous avez froid
en cette nouvelle mesure effectivement
du moment que l'on va restreindre un
tout petit peu le brassage les
rassemblements les déplacements on va
être efficace sans nul doute sur la
progression de l'épidémie
donc simplement effectivement le niveau
de restriction va conditionner la
vitesse avec laquelle on va pouvoir
diminuer la progression de l'épidémie
je dirais c'est un juste milieu à
nouveau entre des mesures très strictes
qui pourrait faire baisser plus
rapidement mais qui serait pas acceptée
et finalement des mesures plus faibles
mais qui serait plus facilement acceptée
donc respectée car à nouveau prendre des
décisions si celles ci ne sont pas
comprises et appliquées par la
population ne sert strictement à rien
d'ailleurs ici il ya un petit pari
effectivement si on autorise les sorties
pendant la journée pour s'aérer
ce qui est tout à fait justifié il faut
évidemment que ça se passe avec une
compréhension de l'esprit de cette
décision c'est à dire sortir pour se
promener mais pas du tout sortir pour
aller voir ses amis et s'enfermer dans
un lieu clos et se contaminer donc on
voit bien malgré tout il faut toujours
poursuivre la pédagogie et l'information
pour que les personnes comprennent
l'esprit des décisions et les applique
yves blanc c'est intéressant ce que ton
dit bruno ben guerdane la compréhension
la pédagogie ce qui frappe c'est un
petit peu le ras-le-bol surtout des
français notamment des les franciliens
qui vivent pas toujours dans des grands
appartements est pour beaucoup
la situation économique devient très
compliqué cette adhésion des français
vous y croyez parce que vous savez
comment ça va être on va pouvoir sortir
certains peut-être vont pas comprendre
ces mesures aient essayé peut-être de
tricher parce que ne comprendront pas
ces mesures justement je crois que vous
continuez à faire l'exercice de
pédagogie nécessaire pour les expliquer
mais je voudrais revenir si vous voulez
bien sur les propos de notre
interlocuteur précédent qu'ils avaient
finalement tout va mal c'est l'horreur
on est des incapables et c'est écoutez
moi je veux bien mais il ya un moment où
il faut pas non plus céder à la
caricature et et pardon de lire au
ridicule quand on est face à une
situation jamais connu extrêmement
mouvante et on a un gouvernement
celui-ci comme d'autres qui face à cela
adoptent des stratégies pour essayer de
se préserver au mieux
une dune d'une catastrophe sans nous
certains pays le font ni chez moi il
blanc je me permets de vous couper je
suis désolé mais mais certains pays
voilà les états unis israël le royaume
uni qui a pu vacciner alors certains ils
ont pu acheter leurs vaccins ils les ont
peut-être payer plus cher il ya un vrai
calendrier précis donc elle même des
gens qui sont dans une meilleure posture
que nous le royaume uni ne fait qu'une
injection sans respecter les délais
recommandés par les entreprises qui
fabriquent des vaccins pour la deuxième
injection pardon de le dire moi j'ai pas
confiance
j'attends de voir comment l'épidémie
comment la protection au royaume uni va
se comporter parce que quand on ne
respecte pas les consignes de ceux qui
ont conçu le vaccin bien en dieu moi je
souhaite bon courage à boris johnson
s'il doit expliquer demain sa population
que oups il s'est trompé et que oui il a
pas respecté les délais qu'il fallait
pour la deuxième
la deuxième injection pour vacciner plus
de monde mais que finalement le premier
vaccin tant qu'il n'a pas eu la deuxième
injection marche moins bien et donc que
la population est mieux protégé par au
bâlois
certains sont libres de prendre ces
risques aulas le premier ministre
britannique l'a pris au mot et hao goody
au bout du compte je pense que c'est de
la responsabilité de chaque gouvernement
d'analyser la situation de s'adapter et
de produire les solutions alors oui
désolé les solutions ne sont pas
toujours d'une simplicité du blick est
explicable en 30 secondes
mais les français sont pas des idéaux
non plus ils sont capables de comprendre
ils sont capables de s'adapter l'ont
déjà démontré qu'il en ait marre mais on
en a tous marre bien sûr c'est normal
c'est une situation dont on a tous en
lui qu elle ce qu'elle se termine mais
en responsabilité et on est aussi
capable les uns et les autres de
comprendre que elle se terminera parce
que on observera un certain nombre de
règles parce que je pense que ça mon
dieu les français sont aussi capables de
le comprendre et entendre jean castex en
est défendue je me propose
d'écouter le premier ministre sur sa
stratégie répondant à la critique d'un
journaliste justement qui lui parler
d'échec du gouvernement l'x paris n'a
pas été gagnée c'est comme l'aveu
d'échec de tout à l'heure je ne partage
pas cette analyse je l'ait déjà indiqué
dans mon intervention tout le monde
effectivement disait dès le 29 janvier
vous devriez re confiné vous souvenez de
stars je pense nous ne l'avons pas fait
nous n'avons pas fait et je pense que
nous avons bien fait parce que peint les
risques les conséquences d'un
confinement sont quand même lourde pour
nos concitoyens et que faire le choix de
se donner les moyens d'en reculer
l'échéance est un choix judicieux
non nous sommes des gens très
pragmatique vous m'entendez vous êtes
fidèle à ses conférences de presse
je vous ai je crois que vous pouvez m'en
donnait toujours dit toujours dit nous
faisons tout pour l'éviter nous devons
tenir ensemble
mais si l'épidémie flambent
alors nous prendrons des mesures je
pense que personne
tout est public et transparent ne peut
contester que j'ai tenus de manière
constante
ce discours je constate avec vous je
constate avec vous et il serait tout à
fait irresponsable de ma part d'agir
autrement qu'aujourd'hui en tout cas
dans un certain nombre de territoires
la situation est devenue suffisamment
préoccupante pour que nous prenions les
mesures adaptées et proportionnées au
moment où l'on doit les prendre
parce qu'elle s'impose bruno m'égare ban
sur cette défense de ne pas avoir
confiné avant alors que la question
était encore sur toutes les lèvres il y
à un mois en tout cas c'était le 29
janvier il aurait peut-être fallu france
et des mesures plus drastiques avant et
ne pas attendre jusqu'au dernier moment
ça aurait sauvé des vies
alors je veux pas m'exprimer en termes
de ça aurait sauvé des vies en tout cas
je ne crois pas ça c'était nécessaire
pourquoi parce que à l'époque l'épidémie
graissez de façon très lente voit même
un moment vers la mi-janvier les la
progression de l'épidémie se réduisent
et donc effectivement il était tout à
fait logique de ne pas confiné à ce
moment-là et de donner sa chance à des
mesures un peu moins strictes comme le
couvre-feu et bien sûr là on va dire la
répétition des informations pour paul
pour la pour le pour les concitoyens
par contre aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation différente en fait on a une
accélération de de la propagation c'est
à dire la vitesse de progression de
l'épidémie augmente et donc évidemment
il ya un risque beaucoup plus important
alors même qu entre temps les services
de réanimation se sont remplis par un
effet qu'une accumulation des patients
qui une fois admis en réanimation pour y
rester pendant 20 à 30 jours et donc
effectivement en raison de nos moyens de
nos lits de réanimation limiter là nous
n'avons plus le choix
moi je suis plutôt partisan du fait que
confiné inutilement et préventivement
n'a pas beaucoup d'intérêt car on le
voit les pays qui l'ont fait à ce moment
là non pas pour autant arrêter leur
confinement c'est le cas de l'allemagne
et l'italie a remis à nouveau un
confinement
donc je crois qu'on aurait eu
probablement un mois ou un mois et demie
de confinement supplémentaires alors que
l'a finalement on va avoir quatre
semaines de confinement absolument
indispensable quatre semaines de
confinement absolument indispensable
vous voyez ajustements à l'écran le
nombre de patients en réanimation dont
vous nous parliez docteur m'égare ban
c'est à dire quasiment le même niveau
qu'en novembre dernier alexis poulain
vous avez commandé longuement sur cette
antenne la stratégie du gouvernement
emmanuel macron qui a toujours affirmé
qu'il souhaitait préserver tout de même
l'économie et que le confinement était
en dernier recours vous lui accordez une
forme de cohérence sur ce point tout à
fait il est tout à fait conscient que le
confinement coûte beaucoup trop cher à
l'économie française qu'on ne pouvait
pas arrêter le pays comme on l'a fait en
mars 2020
c'est moins 1,8 5 points de pib qu'on a
perdu en 2020 même si quelques
indicateurs sont dans le bon sens on est
loin d'une reprise économique et et
refaire un confinement le choix du
confinement on ne peut que saluer la
décision du chef de l'état de l'avoir
repoussé au maximum de la voix tout fait
pour l'éviter mais ce pari il est perdu
bien entendu puisqu'on se retrouve à
devoir confiné donc on agit alors c est
de façon d'être agit bien de dire mais
en france on est quand même les seuls à
avoir confinement plus couvrent peu plus
haut taux attestation est ce que c'est
bien nécessaire cette folie
administrative est ce que on a besoin
d'en faire autant quand nos voisins n'en
font pas autant l'allemagne quand elle
confine c'est pas du tout comme nous et
puis on a aussi l'exception française où
le variant de français c'est le
confinement avec les écoles ouvertes
là encore on est les seuls à le faire en
europe pourquoi quelle est la logique
si vous confiné qu'on veut descendre le
r alors pourquoi décide-t-on de laisser
des écoles ouvertes jusqu'au bout en dix
ans ce sera uniquement quand on n'aura
plus le choix qu'on devra fermer les
écoles aucune logique là encore
donc c'est vraiment toutes ces questions
stratégiques qui pose question pourquoi
la france décide de faire ça pas pas du
tout ce en coordination avec les voisins
sachant que on n'a pas de retour encore
et j'attends de voir la fin le
couvre-feu a permis d'avoir un plateau à
300 morts par jour quand même donc on a
évité peut-être une flambée mais ça
reste à la marge ses mesures
liberticides
elle reste quand même le parent pauvre
de la politique sanitaire puisque
derrière c'était des vaccins des doses
de vaccin qu'il aurait fallu ai eu
encore une fois on voit bien on est en
retard sur tout on a été en retard sur
les masques on arrêtait retard sur les
tests la stratégie d'isolement qui n'a
pas fonctionné
et aujourd'hui on est en retard sur les
vaccins alors c'est pas que la faute du
gouvernement bien entendu et la
commission européenne qui est
responsable dans la façon dont elle a
fait les commandes la façon dont les
vaccins sont produis aussi les
entreprises les big pharma qui ne livre
pas ce qu'elle s'était engagée à livrer
donc c'est à ces sauts de problème qui
fait que les chiffres annoncés ce soir
par jean castex soit ambitieux 10
millions à la mi-avril de français
vaccinés puis 20 millions puis 30
millions bonjour ya une émotion ne
pardonnez moi il ya eu une annonce pour
tendre à cet objectif important que ce
soir aussi c'est que la france reprendra
donc d'ici vendredi un les vaccinations
d'astrazeneca je vous propose d'écouter
jean castex
il veut donner l'exemple et rassurer
écouter dès demain matin la haute
autorité de santé françaises qui est
chargé dans notre pays de formuler les
indications de tel ou tel vaccin
actualisera sa recommandation s'agissant
du vaccin
astrazeneca afin que nous puissions
reprendre immédiatement
dans la foulée dès demain après midi
la campagne de vaccination et comme je
lai déjà indiqué je me ferai moi-même
vacciner demain après midi avec ce
vaccin pour montrer que nous pouvons
avoir toute confiance ou là on voit bien
l'intention du premier ministre qui a
bien compris que la confiance des
français avec ce vaccin ça serait
quelque chose de compliqué une bonne
chose que jean cassette donne l'exemple
et coûté en tout cas moi je suis
soulagée qu'on puisse reprendre la
vaccination avec avec sélection puisque
on dispose d'un nombre de doses qui va
permettre de maintenir l'objectif en
volume que l'on s'est donné de vacciner
donc bon que le premier ministre le
faste devant les caméras je pense que ça
peut être à son envoyé un message aux
français pour leur dire voyez quoi il
n'ya pas le risque a été levée il a été
analysée c'était bien qu'il le soit il
n'a pas lieu d'être
donc on reprend la vaccination et je
pense que c'était une
c'est une bonne nouvelle de même que
c'est une bonne nouvelle moi je le vois
dans ma circonscription en tout cas de
voir que dans les ehpad par exemple les
personnes âgées que me retourner dans
les ensembles recours trouver des
moments de convivialité partagé revoir
leur famille embrasser les
petits-enfants bon écoutez tout n'est
pas si noir que ça évidemment la
situation est compliquée elle est déjà
depuis un an mais on sait mais il ya des
signes d'embellie qu'il faut savoir
aussi lire et ceci en font partie tendu
que la vaccination puisse reprendre
on va poser la question au docteur megan
parce qu'on sait que les soignants ne se
sont pas forcément bousculer au
portillon pour se faire vacciner par
l'astre à zenica rue
une bonne chose ce retour du vexin
docteur oui bien sûr effectivement m'a
jamais douté de notre côté du rapport
bénéfice risque extrêmement favorable de
ce vaccin c'est vrai quelques signaux de
maladies thromboemboliques sont apparus
désormais la lumière est faite sur 7 sur
ses effets secondaires
en fait ils ne sont pas du tout liés au
vaccin et donc on peut reprendre les
choses très certainement il faut bien
sûr remobiliser l'ensemble des soignants
pour se faire vacciner
je crois que les choses vont démarrer
car effectivement les gens ont bien
compris que désormais pour sortir de ce
marasme de ces stop and go répété celle
la vaccination va nous permettre de
retrouver une vie normale donc allons-y
que nous nous vaccinons et nous pourrons
définitivement tourné la page des
restrictions et retrouver une vie quasi
normale
probablement dès l'été merci on finira
sur cette petite note positive si l'on
est merci à bruno ménard va de mercier
alexis poulin et à yves blanc d'avoir
été avec moi donc pour commenter ces
annonces du premier ministre resté avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de l' escalade entre vladimir
poutine et joe biden le premier propose
au deuxième et une discussion diffusé en
direct vendredi ou lundi le président
russe qui un peu plus tôt affirmé je
cite que nous voyons toujours en l'autre
nos propres caractéristiques et qui il
défendra les intérêts russes sur
président américain son côté dit ce soir
ne pas regretter d'avoir qualifié
poutine de tueurs
[Musique]
oui
gilet jaune au début ce n'était pas un
mouvement politique le peuple français
était arrivé au bout de ce qu'il pouvait
supporter il ya énormément de problèmes
en france comment se fait-il qu'on est
les impôts les plus élevés d'europe
comment se fait-il qu'on est les
déficits les plus importants
et comment se fait-il que nous dans les
campagnes on n'est même plus de service
public quand je vois l'état du pays
aujourd'hui
honnêtement j'ai mal au coeur c'est
justement tout le sens de la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
là qu'il va falloir que les gens
apportent des réponses et moi je crois
que de toute façon on ne peut pas régler
les problèmes avec ceux qui les ont
créés c'est impossible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez
réaction attendue aujourd'hui devenir
poutine 24 heures après que le président
américain l'a qualifié de tueur le chef
du kremlin propose à son homologue
américain une discussion diffusé en
direct dans les jours qui viennent
d'eddy merckx chine qui en a profité
également pour réaffirmer que la russie
qu'on use d'un défend ses intérêts et
que le pays prévoit d'entretenir des
relations avec tout le monde y compris
les états unis
bien qu'il pense que nous soyons comme
eux nous sommes différents nous avons un
code génétique culturelle et morale
différents mais nous savons défendre nos
propres intérêts et nous travaillerons
avec eux mais dans les domaines qui nous
intéresse nous et aux conditions que
nous considérons comme bénéfique pour
nous mêmes et ils devront en tenir
compte
ils devront en tenir compte et malgré
toutes les tentatives d'arrêter notre
développement malgré les sanctions et
les insultes
ils devront en tenir compte quant à nous
je parle de nos intérêts nationaux nous
entretiendrons des relations avec tous
les pays du monde y compris les états
unis sa direction également des états
unis la porte parole de la maison
blanche a pris la parole aujourd'hui pas
de réponse quant à l'invitation aux
russes pour une discussion directe mais
un point commun celui de vouloir
travailler ensemble le président biden
et le président poutine ont certainement
des points de vue différents sur leurs
pays respectifs sur la manière d'aborder
l'engagement dans le monde
mais là où ils sont d'accord ce que nous
devons continuer à travailler chercher
des moyens de travailler ensemble comme
cela a été l'hôte et dans les
commentaires du président poutine
il y à des domaines d'intérêts mutuels
et un autre point d'achoppement il y à
cet enjeu aujourd' l'admirent poutine
signé le traité de réunification de
crime et à la russie deux jours plus tôt
les habitants de la péninsule voté oui à
97% pour leur attachement à la
fédération russe
elles les autorités ukrainiennes et les
puissances orientale se refuse à
reconnaître ce fait et en appliquer des
sanctions à la russie la crimée restera
russe que cela plaise ou non a réaffirmé
hier le ministre des affaires étrangères
le sort et l'avenir de la crimée sont à
jamais lié à la russie que cela plaise
ou non
aucune démarche des états occidentaux
menée par les états unis d'amérique ne
peut changer cette réalité que ce soit
du point de vue du droit international
ou d'un point de vue politique ou morale
de son côté notre diplomatie continuera
à travailler vigoureusement afin
d'enraciner dans l'esprit des
partenaires étrangers
les réalités liées au retour de la
péninsule dans le giron de la patrie et
galvanisé par le soutien de washington
l'ukraine envisage un sommet en août
prochain sur la question d'un retour de
la crimée au sein de l'ukraine pour
moscou le dossier est clos avec ce
référendum qui s'est tenu le 16 mars
retour en images sur ce scrutin et les
sanctions qui ont suivi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la crimée escalade verbale entre joe
biden et vladimir poutine autant de
sujets qui tendent encore un peu plus la
relation entre les etats-unis et la
russie pour en parler nous sommes avec
jean de gliniasty directeur de recherche
à l'institut de relations
internationales et stratégiques
bonsoir jean ii
merci d'être avec nous deux décennies de
relations plus ou moins tendues entre
vladimir poutine et les présidents
américains successifs mais là c'est le
pompon si j'ose dire le président
américain qui traite le président russe
de tueurs ça fait un petit peu désordre
quand même est-ce que joe biden a
dépassé les limites selon vous que
cherchent-ils il est clair que c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire ce n'est pas
dans les usages diplomatiques de
qualifier le président du gang puissance
de 2 tu crois qu'au pire moment de la
guerre froide
ce genre de qualificatif n'a jamais été
n'a jamais été utilisée donc il est
manifeste que d'abord ça n'a pas été
utilisé au hasard
ça illustre la dégradation des relations
entre les états unis démocrates et la
russie actuelle et en fait on voit bien
que prolonge un petit peu l'état
d'esprit que byden en tant que vice
président d'obama avait à l'époque et
donc on voit que la politique démocrate
vis-à-vis de la russie sera très dur en
plus ça manifestent une certaine
comment dirais-je on passe un peu la
russie par profits et pertes dans le jeu
triangulaire avec que pékin puisque
visiblement si on veut essayer de faire
en sorte que la russie ne soit pas trop
proche de pékin dans ce jeu triangulaire
on devrait plutôt essayer de l'aménager
ce n'est pas le cas je crois que la
russie dans le la rivalité pékin et
washington est passée un peu par office
d'épée d'ailleurs joe biden un qui dit
clairement vadimir poutine qu il en
paiera le prix
pourquoi sony secours au son du rock
justement avec la russie et est plus
tendre avec peut-être des pays
ma foi peut-être moins fréquentables
aussi alors je crois d'abord qu'il ya un
côté psychologique important cette
histoire d'interférence dans les
élections américaines a des conséquences
psychologiques
beaucoup plus grave qu'on imagine
peut-être en dehors des états unis
la démocratie américaine est considérée
comme iconique si je puis dire parce et
ses citoyens et donc le fait qu'on
accuse la russie d'avoir d'être
intervenu dans le processus électoral a
du poids est un élément qui n'est pas à
négliger dans le dans la proche enfin
dans les propos tenus par baden la
deuxième chose aussi c'est que le bail
den depuis qu'il est arrivé au pouvoir
se présente un peu comme le chef du camp
démocrate et je crée une espèce de
solidarité fondée sur la promotion de la
démocratie les droits de l'homme et les
américains se valent à nouveau un peu le
gendarme de ce genre de choses pour
créer un camp démocratique et évidemment
les propos tenus contre le président
russe s'inscrivent dans cette danse est
biologique donc plus alors oui le camp
démocratique justement lors l'allemagne
semble vouloir faire partie de ce camp
on va faire voilà c'est pas une surprise
mais la bad a clairement pris est parti
aujourd'hui pour washington soutient joe
biden dans ses propos la france va soit
il selon vous l'ancien ne peux pas vous
le dire
e en général ce genre de propos d' n'est
pas conforme à mu âge diplomatique est
en général rend la france essaye de de
respecter ces usages alors en tout cas
le chef de la diplomatie anthony blinken
américain en a profité pour appeler
toutes les entités impliquées dans le
projet controversé du gazoduc nord
stream ii entre la russie et l'allemagne
à se désengager immédiatement sous peine
de sanctions des etats-unis a pas une
forme d'ingérence caractérisée
dans le fait justement d'appeler ces
pays à se désengager sous peine de
sanctions mais je crois que l'extra
territorialité de droit américain et
brandi depuis déjà depuis le temps
d'obama en fait et quand on entre dans
un système de sanctions vis-à-vis de la
russie un gang dans un système aussi où
le gouvernement des états unis le
ministère des finances et des affaires
étrangères juge si le respect ou le non
respect des sanctions par d'autres
entreprises d'autres pays et
préjudiciable aux intérêts concurrentiel
delà de la rue deux des états unis et
donc l'extraterritorialité du système
des sanctions est une donnée est acquise
pour les états unis qui s'en servent
comme il le souhaite alors à cette
escalade verbale entre les deux
présidents s'ajoute la question de la de
la crimée à sept ans après le g7 ne
reconnaîtra pas les tentatives de la
russie visant à légitimer l'occupation
de la crim r je cite les propos du g7
donc sept ans après le dossier nommé
touvent pato bien je crois que au
contraire il et il revient à la surface
et ça n'est probablement pas un hasard
je vous rappelle que dans les accords de
minsk qui avait été signé en tout cas
pas trop mes co signée par la france
l'allemagne les etats-unis veulent le
pardon au contraire la russie et
l'ukraine
il n'est pas fait mention de la crimée
donc ce approuvé l'annexion d'activer
par la russie les pays européens jusque
là considéré que l' affaire ne devait
pas être mise sur le sur la table si on
voulait régler les points les plus durs
le fait que la la clim et reviennent à
la surface et manifestement le signe
d'un durcissement de la situation
internationale
la crimée ukraine amul remis laquelle la
commission la table et les états unis
wamiz aussi donc c'est un c'est un signe
qui ne trompe pas de l'aggravation de la
situation la communauté universelle qui
parle toujours de l'annexion illégale il
ya pourtant eu un référendum ça n'a
aucune valeur aux yeux de ces pays
quelle que soit j'allais dire les les
fondements historiques ou les
justifications stratégique et le voeu
des populations en termes de droit
international stricto sensu il s'agit
d'une d'une annexion mais évidemment par
la suite il pourra y avoir un référendum
reconnu par la communauté internationale
qui tue prendra en compte le voeu
manifeste de la majorité de la
population qui même d'être rattachée à
la russie merci beaucoup jean de
gliniasty directeur de recherche à
l'institut de relations internationales
et stratégiques d'avoir été avec nous et
dans ce contexte de tension croissante
entre washington et moscou une
délégation diplomatique américaine est
aujourd'hui dans la capitale russe
au menu l'avenir de l'afghanistan autour
de la table les membres du gouvernement
afghan des talibans ainsi que des
représentants américains et russes
et ce alors qu'un nouvel attentat a eu
lieu ce matin à kaboul
une attaque à la bombe contre un bus
gouvernementale bilan provisoire au
moins quatre morts et neuf blessés il
s'agit du deuxième attentat similaire
cette semaine le pays reste en proie au
terrorisme ont souvent revendiqué par
belge pierre fi sabil and joe biden
souhaiterait-il retarder le départ des
troupes américaines en afghanistan
c'est en tout cas ce que semble dire à
demi mots le nouveau locataire de la
maison blanche
pour lui la date du 1er mai 2021 convenu
entre talibans et l'ancienne
administration arrive un peu trop tout
cela peut arriver mais c'est difficile
je suis en train de prendre la décision
sur la date de leur départ
le fait est que l'accord conclu par
l'ancien président n'a pas été négocié
de manière très solide
un départ retardé des troupes
américaines ne serait pas vraiment une
manoeuvre apprécié des talibans ces
derniers espèrent que la date convenue
sera honoré sous peine de représailles
les américains devraient mettre fin à
leur occupation conformément à la corde
doha et retirer l'ensemble de leurs
troupes d'afghanistan d'ici au 1er mai
s'ils ne le font pas ils seront
responsables des conséquences
c'est donc dans ce contexte que
plusieurs acteurs de la paix en
afghanistan se rencontrent aujourd'hui à
moscou la russie qui espère bien jouer
un rôle de médiateur dans le conflit
comme l'indiquent le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov
nous appelons les deux parties à rester
attachés aux dispositions de ce document
soutenu par la résolution 2000 513 du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu nous
regrettons que les efforts déployés pour
relancer le processus politique à doha
n'est pas encore donné de résultats
nous espérons que la conversation
d'aujourd'hui contribuera à créer les
conditions nécessaires à la réalisation
de négociations inter afghane
progressiste nous considérons que dans
une situation militaro politique
dégradante de nouveaux retards sont
inacceptables une réunion qui pourrait
servir de base avant une nouvelle
entrevue au mois d'avril en turquie pour
tenter d'apaiser les tensions
américains et russes se sont récemment
montrés favorables à la création d'un
gouvernement de transition incluant des
talibans proposition rejetée par le
gouvernement afghan
c'est donc un défi de taille qui attend
aujourd'hui les acteurs de cette réunion
à moscou pour tenter de ramener la paix
en afghanistan et pour en parler nous
sommes avec gérard vespière analyse
politique chercheur associé à la fée
maubon soir gérard
merci d'être avec nous tout d'abord que
doit-on pas pcq audois temps d'attendre
des nouvelles négociations qui se passe
à moscou en ce moment un début de début
de convergence entre effectivement le
pouvoir actuel à à kaboul
d'autre part les talibans et
troisièmement donc les représentants
américains et aussi de l'otan il y a ne
l'oublions pas trois fois plus de
soldats de l'otan que deux soldats
purement américain à eau en afghanistan
donc c'est là le but et il ya un triple
défi dans cette situation là il y a un
défi intérieur pour la stabilité en
afghanistan
il y a un défi aussi extérieure parce
que un afghanistan instable aurait des
répercussions sur les voisins directs
genre pakistan ou bien un peu plus
éloigné la russie acquis à 15% à 2 sarah
population musulmane est aussi dans le
sud à des territoires qui sont très très
ajdir est sensible à une islamisation
grandissante
donc il ya deux défis ici le troisième
c'est à l'intérieur de la société
afghane et et bien effectivement un peu
une rivalité entre ville et campagne
campagne conservatrice villes qui ont
donné un peu plus de liberté où la femme
a eu d'autres opportunités d'étudier et
de travailler
donc il ya really à un défi à
l'intérieur de la société auxquels
s'ajoute l'arrivée de l'état islamique
alors l'état islamique précisément les
états unis annoncent qu'ils vont retirer
leurs troupes même sera difficile il
sera difficile de le faire d'ici le 1er
mai un joe biden l'a annoncé qu'elle
serait
l'impact justement de ce retrait des
troupes américaines concernant le retour
de l'islamiste le de l'islamisme et des
djihadistes sur place donc les troupes
américaines sont mêmes celles de l'otan
incluse ne représente qu'une fraction
des forces de sécurité en afghanistan
par rapport à la police afghane et à
l'armée afghanes donc tout ne peut pas
dépendre d'eux au contraire à tous des
propos sur les épaules des forces
intérieures afghane
et c'est bien là le défi est ce que ces
forces là vous êtes à même de combattre
à la fois les talibans et aussi l'état
islamique qui posait un problème
politique à aux talibans car les
talibans avant l'arrivée de l'état
islamique était la partie la plus
radicale de la société afghane
maintenant qu'il y à naissance de l'état
islamique en afghanistan et bien les
talibans sont un petit peu si je puis
dire centralisés sont dans la géométrie
politique a mis un peu au centre par
rapport à une aile extrémiste et de
l'autre côté le gouvernement donc il y à
une géométrie politique aussi
intéressante et nouvelles a observé
est-ce que ça passera par l'instauration
d'un gouvernement provisoire
c'est ce qui est demandé c'est ce qui
est souhaitable qu'elle conçoit après
les évolutions il ya effectivement la
nécessité de mettre en place une
nouvelle constitution et d'avoir à une
ratification populaire et démocratique
donc c'est hautement souhaitable mais là
on est dans le jeu tactique n'est ce pas
les talibans n'ayant pas arrêté les
attentats le pouvoir en place
refusant à un partage de ce pouvoir
on sent qu'on est dans la dernière ligne
droite des négociations et donc tout le
monde veut pousser un petit peu à la
surenchère de l'autre partie alors dans
ces négociations il ya un grand absent
c'est l'otan qui est pourtant présente
sur le terrain d'opérations afghan
comment expliquez vous cette absence
disons que nous sommes l'otan était
présent en tant que force de de
formation de l'armée afghane des forces
de sécurité afghanes n'y a pas une
présence en termes vraiment politique
n'est ce pas c'est vraiment la
représentation américaine qui joue ce
rôle là et donc depuis le début de la
situation en afghanistan depuis 2003
donc c'est une situation acquise dans
cette structure où les états unis sont
effectivement le leader de cette
activité un militaire et et politique
merci beaucoup ans gérard vestiaires
analyse géopolitique chercheur associé à
la fée mots nous avoir apporté votre
analyse ce soir dans le reste de
l'actualité aux pays-bas les numéros
remportent les élections législatives et
c'est un quatrième mandat en vue pour le
premier ministre sortant au pouvoir
depuis dix ans c'était le premier
scrutin national organisé dans un pays
de l'ue en pleine crise sanitaire
visiblement les manifestations anti
restrictions leur ont pas eu vraiment
d'impact sur les résultats françois
xavier lambert c'est en premier ministre
satisfait qui vient s'exprimer devant la
presse après la publication des premiers
résultats
selon les estimations le parti libéral
vvd a obtenu 35 sièges sur les 150 de la
chambre basse du parlement
en résultat qui devrait permettre à marc
route de diriger sa quatrième coalition
gouvernementale je suis très content
très heureux pour la quatrième fois et
c'est très spécial je le suis aussi
d'avoir eu l'honneur de gérer certaines
crises majeures la récession la crise
des réfugiés et maintenant la crise du
coronavirus en tant que grand parti cela
nous rend très humble
c'est un immense honneur au pouvoir
depuis 2010 marque route avait
démissionné mi janvier sur fond de
scandales financiers tout en poursuivant
la gestion des affaires courantes
désormais il va pouvoir former son
nouveau gouvernement le premier ministre
néerlandais a jugé probable une
coalition avec deux parties
le d66 sociales libérales et les
chrétiens démocrates
il a en revanche exclu toute négociation
avec les députés du parti de geert
wilders le pvv
ce dernier a assuré qu'il continuera à
faire entendre sa voix je pense que nous
sommes toujours le troisième parti des
pays-bas
si les proportions sont toujours comme
on les voit nous sommes probablement de
nouveau le plus grand parti d'opposition
et puis nous ferons entendre la voix du
pvv
depuis l'opposition avec beaucoup de
force et enthousiasme dans les années à
venir
ces législatives néerlandaises se sont
déroulés durant trois jours pour
permettre aux électeurs les plus
vulnérables de voter avec un minimum de
risques le scrutin constitue aussi un
test pour le gouvernement sortant en
partie jugée sur sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire
une stratégie évolutive avec des mesures
renforcées peu à peu depuis un an après
avoir misé sur l'immunité collective
l'exécutif a durci sa position depuis
septembre restaurant bar écoles fermées
couvre-feu imposé malgré de violentes
manifestations
les autorités ont tenu le cap et
convaincu les électeurs de leur redonner
leur confiance le nouveau gouvernement
va désormais devoir se concentrer sur la
campagne de vaccination ralenti après la
suspension pour deux semaines du vaccin
d'astrazeneca plus de un million neuf
cent mille doses ont été administrées
jusqu'à présent aux pays bas il reste
avec mon dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de joe biden qui provoque la
première crise diplomatique de son
mandat avec la russie le président
américain serait-il plus belliqueux que
ce pur on pouvait penser ce sera l'objet
notre face à face et puis nous
reviendrons sur la situation sanitaire
en france 16 départements en temps sous
la coupe d'un nouveau confinement
décrété pour quatre semaines en ile de
france dans les hauts de france l'eure
la seine maritime et les alpes-maritimes
à compter de vendredi minuit
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
le maniement de la rumeur est vieux
comme le monde mais il est vrai que
l'arrivée des réseaux sociaux il va
donner une crédibilité destructrices
dans sa virtualité l'influencent a pris
toute sa place au coeur des
affrontements politiques et économiques
internationaux car elle est une
manifestation de la puissance capable de
peser sur l'évolution des situations
tous les jours nous entendons des
accusations de complotisme contre ceux
qui n'adhèrent pas à la pensée compte
dans le fond la théorie du complot
l'explication la plus simple et la plus
facile d'autant qu'elle permet de
désigner un bouc émissaire
évidemment au wable dupire vouloir
forcer le destin en récrivant une
histoire biaisée pour servir ses
intérêts ne tient pas dans la durée car
la vérité finit toujours par éclater
[Musique]
l'actualité hervé morin c'est évidemment
la crise sanitaire ce que je défends
c'est bien sûr la territorialisation
d'injection d'épidémie à voit bien qu un
système centralisé bureaucratique tel
que celui ci a produit toute une série
de dysfonctionnements pas de masque dans
un premier temps pas de test dans un
second temps puis désormais une
insuffisance de vaccins on a senti que
vous étiez nerveux et agacé à l'encontre
de la politique de l'exécutif quant à au
déploiement de la vaccination et je
constate c'est que l'on est le 36e pays
en matière de vaccination
bon ça prouve à quel point on a un
système efficace
en normandie on aura deux usines qui
bientôt produiront des vaccins qui pour
l'un va être bientôt autorisés sur le
marché compte tenu de la faiblesse de la
vaccination je vois pas comment dans
quatre à six semaines
on pourrait se retrouver libéré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une crainte de l'inflation a poussé les
investisseurs à vendre des obligations
conséquence une forte remontée des taux
sur le marché c'est plutôt un
avertissement des marchés vis-à-vis de
la banque centrale de lui dire attention
même si l'économie repart
il n'est pas question que vous changiez
politique ne faudra pas que les
investisseurs jeu trop longtemps parce
que c'est une grosse main comme on dit à
la réserve fédérale américaine c'est
celle qui dispose de la machine à
premier des billets de banque dans la
cave et qui a la capacité en fait de la
faire fonctionner sans aller en prison
plutôt ne peuvent pas donc on va forcer
en fait les banques centrales à
continuer à faire tourner la planche à
billets comme d'habitude cette
thématique n existait pas ya trois mois
elle n'existera plus dans trois mois
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple a
accepté une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort
du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose d'inouï
gilet jaune c'était des valeurs de
droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
c'est
[Musique]
un certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre l'eau politiques et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité
c'est le sentiment d'exister
d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde il
est vrai que la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
il est 21h merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce jeudi 18 mars
joe biden provoque la première crise
diplomatique de son mandat deux mois
après son entrée à la maison blanche si
ces tweets pas ce inaperçus ces
dernières sorties jette un froid glacial
entre la russie et les etats unis le
président qui veut réconcilier
l'amérique se montrent particulièrement
offensif avec vladimir poutine alors
derrière les insultes une dangereuse
escalade initiée par un président plus
belliqueux que prévu ce sera l'objet de
notre face à face au soir face à la
troisième vague 16 départements tombe
sous la coupe d'un nouveau confinement
décrété pour quatre semaines en ile de
france dans les hautes france l'eure la
seine maritime et les alpes-maritimes à
compter de vendredi minuit dans le reste
du territoire le couvre-feu est décalé à
19 heures en métropole dès samedi
côté vaccination le régulateur européen
juge le versé 1,3 et les cassures et
efficace jean castex fera vacciner ce
vendredi
[Musique]
une petite bonne nouvelle un dans le
marasme ambiant la banque de france
prévoit un rebond un peu plus forte que
prévu de l'économie avec une croissance
de 5 5% cette année dans ces conditions
le retour de l'activité à son niveau pré
qu'ovide interviendrait dès le printemps
prochain en 2022 dont 10 la banque
centrale alors un tel scénario n'est
t'il pas trop optimiste à l'heure où la
campagne de vaccination piétinées alors
houleux on sonne leur confinement dans
seize départements c'est ce que nous
verrons tout à l'heure avec l'économiste
jacques sapir
[Musique]
l' escalade entre vladimir poutine et
joe biden le premier propose donc au
deuxième une discussion diffusé en
direct vendredi ou lundi le président us
crie un peu plus tôt affirmé je cite que
nous voyons toujours en l'autre nos
propres caractéristiques et qu'il
défendra les intérêts russes
vous l'aurez compris l'ambiance et n'est
pas du tout au beau fixe entre les deux
dirigeants
les précisions à moscou d'antoine
claireaux bonsoir antoine velimir
cousine a donc réagi cet après midi aux
déclarations de joe biden oui tout à
fait dans un premier temps vladimir
poutine a répondu par une pirouette en
renvoyant joe biden a sa propre attaque
en déclarant je cite que lorsqu'on tente
de juger d'autres gens ou même d'autres
pays où d'autres peuples
on se regarde toujours en quelque sorte
dans un miroir et de la dirco ty ne
s'est pas contenter de simplement
commenté la saillie verbale du président
américain
en retour il a proposé à son homologue
de débattre ensemble en direct et ce
dans les tout prochains jours
écoutez nous ne devons pas échangé dans
le dos de l'autre nous pouvons et nous
devons poursuivre une relation proche
d'ailleurs j'y ai pensé la dernière fois
que nous avons une conversation
téléphonique
l'initiative est venue du président
biden je voudrais proposer au président
buydens poursuivre notre discussion mais
à condition que nous fassions en direct
en ligne comme on dit il s'agirait d'une
discussion ouverte en direct et nous
pourrions parler des relations
bilatérales de la stabilité stratégique
et du traitement des conflits régionaux
et il y en a beaucoup
reagan aline filipp d autres défis
auxquels l'humanité est confrontée
aujourd'hui
tu aurais vu juste le président russe a
proposé la date de ce vendredi 19 mars
ou bien lundi après le week end
il a également ajouté que des
instructions dans ce sens allait être
donné au ministère des affaires
étrangères la balle est donc maintenant
dans le camp du locataire de la maison
blanche et antoine cette passe d'armes
est aussi lié à la publication d'un
rapport du renseignement américain qui
accuse la russie d'ingérence lors de la
dernière élection présidentielle aux
états unis comment les autorités russes
ont elles réagi mais bien la diplomatie
russe a dans un premier temps répondu
sur la forme sur cette attaque verbale
de joe biden avant ensuite de répondre
sur le fond de cette nouvelle accusation
je vous laisse écouter l'administration
américaine actuelle ne cesse de
surprendre par l'absurdité de ces
déclarations publiques
je fais référence non seulement aux
attaques contre les dirigeants russes
qui dépasse toutes les limites de la
décence mais aussi aux accusations
absurdes d'ingérence dans les élections
présidentielles de l'année dernière le
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
qui a également rappelé à moscou son
ambassadeur en poste à washington afin
de définir la stratégie à adopter afin
de décider de la suite à donner à cette
affaire et antoine washington qui a
aussi menacé de sanction des entités
impliquées dans le gazoduc north stream
de oui le chef de la diplomatie
américaine a appelé jeudi dans un
communiqué toutes les entités impliquées
dans le projet de gazoduc à se
désengager immédiatement sous peine de
sanctions américaines qui au passage
dénoncé je cite un projet géopolitique
russe visant à diviser l'europe et
affaiblir sa sécurité énergétique
cette annonce intervient alors même que
les travaux de ce gazoduc russo allemand
achevé à plus de 95% avait justement
repris depuis le mois de février
après de longs mois d'arrêt en raison
déjà de sanctions américaines
merci antoine au clairon en direct de
moscou et propos du président américain
à l'encontre de son homologue
sont surpris une nouvelle prise de
position clivante sur la scène
internationale alors que les premières
décisions concrètes se font encore
attendre deux mois après son investiture
la stratégie diplomatique de joe biden
restent encore incertaines
les précisions avec robin pu l joe biden
réoriente la diplomatie américaine
retour dans les traités internationaux
hostilité affichée à l'encontre de la
russie
remise en cause du soutien à l'arabie
saoudite depuis son entrée en fonction
le président américain a multiplié les
prises de position avec un objectif
clair rompre avec la stratégie de son
prédécesseur donald trump un choix
réaffirmé dès le début du mois de
février lors de son premier discours sur
la politique internationale prononcé au
département d'état l'amérique est de
retour l'amérique est de retour et la
diplomatie est de retour c est au centre
de tout ce que j'ai l'intention de faire
nous allons réparer nos alliances nous
engager à nouveau avec le monde non pas
pour relever les défis d'hier mais ceux
d'aujourd'hui et de demain
le leadership américain doit faire face
à ce nouveau moment de progression de
l'autoritarisme mais deux mois après
l'investiture de joe biden les décisions
fermes sur les dossiers brûlants se font
attendre
comme par exemple à propos du nucléaire
iranien joe biden a fait du retour des
etats unis dont l'accord devienne une
priorité mais sans acte concret
washington semble encore bien éloigné de
la table des négociations
une forme d'inaction qui interroge de
plus en plus outre atlantique et qui
fait craindre une aggravation de la
situation
je pense que l'administration maiden a
raté une occasion au cours des premières
semaines de son mandat d'envoyer un
signal plus fort et plus concret de ses
intentions de bonne foi de revenir dans
l'accord de vienne pendant le temps
qu'il a fallu à l'équipe biden pour
commencer à être plus proactive les
positions se sont durcies en iran
surnommé joe lando remis par donald
trump au cours de la campagne
présidentielle
joe biden tente d'afficher des positions
incisive sur la scène internationale
avec le risque comme son prédécesseur de
fragiliser les discussions avec certains
partenaires internationaux est joe biden
souvent présenté lors de la campagne
présidentielle comme plus apaisé on va
dire que son prédécesseur adopte donc un
ton détonnant une agressivité verbale à
l'égard à laquelle on s'attendait pas
nécessairement
est ce que le président américain se
trompent qu'ils empirent
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir est avec nous pour en parler un
républicain nicolas scamps caire vous
êtes le porte parole des républicains
overseas france un démocrate et all
aubry vous êtes l'animateur du compte on
s'aide ue etc sur twitter l'ancien
animateur du club bernie sanders france
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous alors on va essayer un petit
peu d'analysé sur la forme et sur le
fond cette déclaration assez surprenante
quand même et tonitruante de joe biden
vladimir poutine qui est un tueur
le président donc américain qui traite
le président russe de deux tueurs
ça vous a choqué nicholas conc'air alors
nous à notre niveau le parti républicain
et les républicains envers 6 on dénonce
formellement ses prises de position qui
bavent coup complètement toute forme
d'accord bilatéral et deux ans de
diplomatie qui a été mis en place
on voit que ça c'est vraiment
préjudiciable pour les intérêts
américains comme pour les citoyens
américains dont je fais partie qui
vivent à l'étranger
ça c'est ça va vraiment c'est du jamais
vu en fait plus d'un chef d'état dans un
temps de paix depuis 75 ans on vit ce
genre de prêt rapide escalade qui a été
donné alors on peut pas me taxer de
sympathie envers monsieur poutine mon
pour en tout cas salué son panache par
rapport à la réponse qu'ils parvenaient
sa maison et l'autre on sait pas si
c'est juste une question et donne dire a
répondu une question alors qu'il y avait
dans les profondeurs et qui est juste
parti un petit peu dans les plans des
dans le décor si il tenait vraiment à
garder ta en tenue et funky marque une
nouvelle nouvelle direction une nouvelle
impulsion donnée à la démocratie
américaine
et qui va pas du tout dans le bon sens
qui est beaucoup plus interventionniste
c'est contre le coi donald trump c'était
complètement opposé le travel banlieue
de nombreux succès diplomatique cours de
son mandat
en tout cas il a assumé parce que voilà
vous dites il lisait un promoteur il a
répondu à une question enfin il a quand
même assumer c'est pas un mot en l'air
parce qu'il a assumé ce soir de ne pas
avoir regretté d'avoir traité veine mais
putin de deux tueurs
est ce qu'on peut dire théo lobry que
joe biden est vraiment dans l'outrance
aujourd'hui on sait finalement quelque
chose qui ne vous choque pas ces propos
alors la première chose que je tenais à
rappeler ces scellés propos de donald
trump qu'il a pu avoir pendant quatre
ans que mon collègue républicain a l'air
d'oublier qu'ils étaient très
certainement soit du même acabit soit à
pire surtout démultiplié en ce qui
concerne ce que dubai donne je pense
quand on suit un petit peu la
trajectoire de joe biden mais ça ne
surprend pas déjà il avait qualifié
milosevic de criminels de guerre en face
à face lors d'une rencontre quand
dessinateur il a qualifié hier dogan à
plusieurs reprises d'autocrates avec des
mots très durs sur le régime turc entre
la régie maire de gan en turquie et
vis-à-vis de la russie la position la
position de joe biden a toujours été
clair même pendant la campagne
c'est une ligne assez ferme alors après
on est d'accord où on n'est pas d'accord
mais je ne pense pas qu'on puisse être
si surpris que ça et je ne pense pas non
plus qu'il faille surinterpréter ce
genre de scène ce genre de propos
puisque que ce soit jo gaiden ou
vladimir poutine sont quand même des
hommes qui sont rationnels pragmatique
et qui connaissent l'un et l'autre les
limites à ne pas franchir voilà c'est
une opposition
monsieur poutine après si le rapport de
force il me semble qu'il ne respecte
même que le rapport de force et dubaï
donne plus affreux ce rapport de force
alors jobs ne nous dit l'amérique est de
retour la diplomatie est de retour
manifestement pas pour tout le monde les
diplomaties nicholas conc'air à la
réponse justement de théo lobry il faut
un rapport de force finalement alors il
n'a pas dit que c'était sain mais
peut-être que c'était là le fond de sa
pensée que d'une certaine manière ça ne
ferait pas de grandes conséquences c'est
votre avis aussi je me basais en fait
sur un plan qui avait initié lors du la
présidence d'obama et lorsque ben hayden
était déjà le vice président à l'époque
donc en 2009 déjà joe biden assumait et
mettant en avant un plan de reset
renouveau des relations entre les
etats-unis et la russie s'avère que ce
plan a été désastre total pour les états
unis
façon bilatérale ne sont pas améliorées
et il est plus de goût est vraiment
pathétique la cette approche shop
bancaire ou vraiment à défier asnières
l'intégrité des élections
c'est vraiment une chose qui est nulle
et non avenue
on peut se demander quels sont les
intérêts des agences de renseignement et
si bailon contrairement à donald trump
lorsqu'il était dans la maison blanche
est-ce que lui céder aux pressions du
complexe militaro-industriel et est ce
que c'est ça vraiment le visage de cette
gauche dite progressiste libéral que
d'être le parti de la guerre théo lobry
est ce que pour vous à l'instar de ce
que nous dit un petit peu
nicholas conc'air est-ce que ça va trop
loin ce que c'est une une escalade qui
peut tout de même s'avérer dangereuse
au bout du compte alors encore une fois
malheureusement je reviens juste
quelques secondes sur ce qu'a dit mon
collègue les publics à le complexe
industrie l'industrie militaire
américaine
c'est très bien portés sous donald trump
puisque le budget de l'armée n'a jamais
été si conséquents et puis je
rappellerai quand même malgré tout les
propos qu'a tenus donald trump notamment
à l'encontre de kim jong-un le traitant
de petit chiot malade sinon est ce que
on va
est-ce que ça risque de poser des
problèmes par la suite
ou est ce que ça pourrait dégénérer des
problèmes il y en a il y en a notamment
depuis 2016 puisque les démocrates sont
vent debout contre la russie par rapport
à l'ingérence supposée aux élections que
moi personnellement je ne dirai knicks
et phonique c'est vrai puisque
finalement c'est assez flou ça c'est
opaque mais je ne pense pas que ça
puisse dégénérer 1
si on prend l'exemple de la syrie
l'intervention russe en syrie par
exemple la russie réagi à la position
américaine plus qu elle ne devance les
américains les américains sous obama ne
veulent pas intervenir en syrie la
russie se positionne sur tout un tas de
sujets comme ça je pense comme je le
disais tout à l'heure que chacun connaît
bien ses limites c'est qu'il n'ya il y a
des choses à ne pas faire et je ne pense
pas que ça dégénère c'est dans l'intérêt
ni des etats-unis de la russie et je
pense qu'on est quand même ça ça des
dirigeants qui ont beaucoup de défauts
c'est très certainement mais qui savent
exactement à quoi s'en tenir au niveau
des relations internationales nicholas
cronk r c'est vrai que trump nous a
habitués
voilà une certaine outrance une certaine
provocation appelé à on l'a comme on
veut
joe biden l'endormi un strict le
qualifier votre poulain vous êtes vous
même
étonné par par cette tonalité parce que
c'est vrai que quand c'est être up qui
prononçait ce genre de phrases san
étonner personne mais joe biden on ne
l'attendait pas là il est peut-être pire
entre guillemets que qu'autrement fou
aujourd'hui donc on peut déjà constater
que au bout de deux mois trump ne manque
déjà on appréciait son style et voilà
son franc parler absent le politiquement
correct et au delà des déclarations
c'est les actions et les résultats qui
pensent ça aboutit les propos envers qui
ont une finale déboucher sur un accord
de paix absolument historique entre les
deux corées on rappellera également des
accords d'abraham qui ont été des
accords de paix entre israël et les pays
voisins
ob donc c'est vraiment un bilan vraiment
historique et encore une fois aucun
nouveau conflit empoché l'or en ce qui
concerne les prises de position je pense
que hayden cherche un pas se donner une
stature en donnant un petit peu des
gages à sa frange la plus extrémiste
elle a pu battre hier je pense que c'est
direction à laquelle il faut revenir et
se concentrer sur les priorités qui sont
d'abord nationales et de continuer sur
cette lancée qui avait initié donald
trump et rijkaard et république sont
tout à fait aligner qui sont de remettre
les états unis au centre du dispositif
d' assurer la réouverture de l'économie
d'assurer que les enfants qui se
retourner à l'école et de prendre en
compte l'urgence crise d'immigration qui
a lieu frontière américaine justement
par rapport à d'autres déclarations que
lui a pu faire quand justement en
ouvrant les vannes des appels d'air à
des régularisations massives de
d'immigrés théo lobry le mot de la fin
nicholas concarneau parler d'immigration
quand on entend joe madden déconseillé
aux migrants justement de rester chez
eux à la frontière mexicaine vous n'êtes
pas un peu déçu par ce président qui
qu'on n'attendait pas nécessairement là
peut-être alors il me semble aussi que
pendant la campagne de dubaï de navets
était assez clair sur sa position
vis-à-vis de l'immigration n'était pas
c'était pas un candidat qui était
forcément très ouvert une immigration
massive aux états unis mais par contre
est ouvert à une régularisation des
personnes qui étaient là depuis qu'ils
étaient sur le sol américain depuis
longtemps notamment notamment les jeunes
donc là encore il n'y a pas vraiment de
il n'y a pas vraiment de surprise ni une
nouveauté
et puis je tiens quand même à dire que
c'est vrai que c'est important pour les
américains que le président qui même le
congrès ce concentre avant tout sur les
problèmes des américains
je pense que joe biden l'a bien compris
puisque liens de viana d'avoir mis sur
pied un plan de 1900 milliards $ un plan
de soutien à l'économie qui selon les
dires de quand même d'un bon nombre
d'économistes va faire du bien aux
classes moyennes et aux classes
populaires aux états unis la campagne de
vaccination qui avait été initié qui
avait été initié en descendant sous
donald trump a pris encore une nouvelle
ampleur avec joe biden puisqu'on est on
est à plus de 100 millions d'injections
de trois vaccins américains et les
objectifs de biden 200 millions en 5
jours sont largement tenu puisque on en
est environ 50 à 60 jours
donc je pense qu'il a bien compris que
la priorité c'était les américains en
premier et ça on peut pas lui reprocher
il me semble merci en tout cas tous les
deux nés colosse conc'air théo lobry
d'avoir accepté ce face-à-face mercier
est beau
en france confinement pour au moins
quatre semaines les annonces du premier
ministre jean castex concerne 16
départements français dans lesquels les
indicateurs sanitaires sont alarmants
quelles sont les conditions de ces
restrictions renforcées
on fait le point en détails avec
grégoire douce et cette énième
conférence de presse sanitaires étaient
particulièrement attendus et l'effort
demandé aux habitants de seize
départements de l'hexagone est une
nouvelle fois conséquent un confinement
d'au moins quatre semaines a été
annoncée par le premier ministre jean
castex face à l'accélération du virus et
face à la pression qui s'accentue sur
nos services hospitaliers nouveau d'où
devant désormais le moment est venu
aller plus loin et mettre en oeuvre des
mesures plus exigeantes dans les
départements dans la situation est la
plus critique ces départements sont donc
au nombre de 16 il s'agit des huit
départements d'île de france
les cinq départements des hauts de
france et puis les alpes-maritimes la
seine maritime et l'eure dans ses seize
départements de nouvelles mesures de
freinage massive de l'épidémie
interviendront à compter de ce vendredi
soir minuit et pour quatre semaines
seuls les commerces qui vendent des
biens dits de première nécessité
resteront ouverts objectif réduire
davantage les contacts dans les lieux
clos a poursuivi le chef du gouvernement
s'agissant des commerces comme en mars
et en novembre seuls les commerces
vendant des biens et des services de
première nécessité seront autorisés à
ouvrir cette notion de biens de première
nécessité sera étendue aux livres et à
la musique ce qui permettra aux
libraires ou disquaires de rester
ouverts par souci d'équité les
restrictions de vente s'appliqueront aux
mêmes produits qu'ils savent qu'ils
soient vendus dans un rayon de grandes
surfaces un commerce spécialisé ou un
petit commerce de centre ville
je sais que les commerçants mis en place
des protocoles sanitaires strictes mais
pour ralentir l'épidémie
il faut réduire les risques de croiser
de virus et donc les occasions de
contacts dans les lieux que
dans le détail c'est un confinement aux
conditions multiples qui est décrétée
écoles et collèges restent ouverts les
lycées poursuivre avec un rythme en 2011
quant aux universités elles continueront
d'accueillir partiellement les étudiants
les déplacements entre régions seront à
nouveau interdite tandis que le
couvre-feu lui sera décalée à 19 heures
à partir de ce samedi
l'exécutif qui demande par ailleurs aux
entreprises d'appliquer le télétravail
au moins quatre jours par semaine
outre ces mesures de confinement la
france compte plus que jamais sur sa
stratégie vaccinale pour enrayer cette
spirale négative
et dans ce cadre les injections du
controversé vaccin d'astrazeneca
reprennent dès ce vendredi dans le pays
à commencer par jean castex lui même et
pour en parler nous sommes avec bertrand
legrand médecin généraliste à tourcoing
dans le nord 1 régions concernées par ce
confinement bonsoir bertrand legrand un
an après et voilà on en est toujours là
retour à la case départ
ça vient juste confirmé une un échec qui
se tient couronné en fait différente
absurdité qu'on a déjà dénoncé à
plusieurs reprises le défaut de masques
a des origines maintenant on a des
basques on peut au moins remercié le
gouvernement pour ça on a des masques
c'est bien ça fait un nom on espère
avoir des vaccins dans un an on espère
que l' isolement soit suffisant des
personnes positives
peut-être dans un an ou dans six mois je
sais pas très bien combien de temps il
faudra en tout cas effectivement on est
arrivé au point de non retour et on est
bien obligé aujourd'hui de confiner pour
pouvoir soulager les services de
réanimation
c'est un échec alors dans le même temps
effectivement on nous dit voilà qu'on
n'a pas priver notre liberté c'est du
confinement mais on nous laisse sortir
s'est this faisant tout cas pour le
médecin que vous êtes il fallait
une fois qu'on a critiqué évidemment ce
que vous venez de faire et ce qu'on a
déjà fait sur ce plateau les mesures
passé c'était ce qu'il fallait faire où
il fallait aller plus loin au contraire
ou moins loin je vois que vous avez vous
même du mal à décrire la totalité de des
allers retours c'est manifestement ce le
couvre-feu et plus tard mais le
confinement est plus sévère forme ne
fait pas très clair on refera qu'on lise
le texte de décret pour bien comprendre
tous les ai tous les éléments de toute
façon lui fallait confiné là on n'avait
plus de peu d'autres possibilités
puisque la sécurité sociale et des
équipes de contact racing libérer tout
le monde à 10 jours alors que certains
étaient encore contagieux que le médecin
traitant ne voyait plus les patients qui
étaient directement gérée par la sécu
bon c'est normal
un non médecins ne sait pas gérer une
épidémie c'est pas une grande nouvelle
on a essayé depuis le mois de septembre
ça marche pas on va peut-être essayer de
revenir à des choses plus concrètes où
le médecin va gérer les personnes
contagieuses et redonner le droit de
sortir aux personnes contagieuses en
attendant il faut faire baisser
effectivement le seul moyen qu'on a de
faire baisser à l'heure actuelle au jus
du nombre des fidèles de l'épidémie du
nombre de personnes atteintes
c'est le confinement on sait bien
malheureux mais il ya que sa chair il ya
certaines incohérences que le médecin
que vous êtes pourrait peut-être nous
aider à décrire
on nous dit maintenant qu'on peut
prendre l'air finalement c'est pas grave
c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à comprendre
au début les enfants étaient privés de
sport à l'école maintenant il ne ne sont
plus alors qu'on est supposé sévir que
comprendre alors si on se reporte
l'interview que vous avez fait il ya un
nom je vous avais déjà expliqué que
c'était un peu étonnant de voir confiné
quelqu'un seul sur un pédalo au milieu
de la mer mais
effectivement en dehors le risque est
assez faible
on sait qu'on a très peu de kloster qui
sont faits en extérieur que les clusters
qui sont faits en extérieur sont
essentiellement sur des regroupements
vraiment collé serré donc ça serait
hâtif est relativement logique ça va
céder mais enfin entre temps on a quand
même eu des confinement strict on a eu
des attestations d'une heure donc voilà
ah oui ou non je sais qu'il faut être
très clair que ça fait un an qu'on fait
plus rien de logique donc que pendant un
an il ya eu des choses totalement
illogique c'est à la limite c'est devenu
logique y'a pas de problème de ce
côté-là les logis cité des prêts mesures
prises antérieurement ça il n'y a pas de
problème tout le monde est d'accord
par contre là cette fois ci pour le coup
nous permettre aux gens de sortir sa
part est relativement logique en
extérieur sans regroupement c'est tout à
fait normal et puis il faut quand même
aussi relâché un peu la pression
par contre faut insister pour les
auditeurs même si le gouvernement est un
peu une logique le virus ne se transmet
que lorsque l'on se regroupe et si peu
et si on quand on se regroupe en milieu
clos donc clairement ce qu'il faut c'est
éviter de se retrouver en réunion de
famille en réunion entre amis
parce que c'est le moment nous on a
besoin d'avoir cette baisse de
l'incidence et si vous attendez que
l'état baissent l'incidence vu que ça
fait un an qu'ils ont pas réussi
bon on va peut-être éviter de compter
sur eux alors il ya quand même une bonne
nouvelle ou pas à sa faim en fonction
reprise demain après-midi des
vaccinations astrazeneca avec jean
castex en tête le médecin généraliste
que vous êtes s'en réjouit
et dans le même temps un seul mot à la
mode il va falloir quand même convaincre
vos patients on imagine que la confiance
est un petit peu entamée non franchement
on est vraiment confiant dans le fait
dans le vaccin astrazeneca on n'avait
pas de souci particulier quand ils l'ont
arrêté très sincèrement c'était une
absurdité complète et si vous lisez
entre les lignes ce que dit le m&a il ya
clairement une condamnation des états
qui ont arrêté la vaccination qui est
dit entre elina presse et du
politiquement correct bien évidemment
mais il n'y avait aucune raison pour un
risque si fier si faible d'arrêter la
vaccination
personnellement j'ai une liste
d'attentes de 400 personnes volontaires
pour être vacciné malheureusement
dimanche prochain je n'aurai que 50 de
vaccins si je suis bien livré demain
donc ma secrétaire s'est organisé pour
appeler demain 50 personnes donc ça fait
pas difficulté non ce qu'on voudrait
vraiment c'est avoir des doses peu
importe le vaccin puisque encore une
fois il n'ya pas que le vaccin est
freinée zenica faut pas oublier que le
vaccin de pfizer ou moderne est tout à
fait injectable en cabinet médical de
ville et pour des raisons toujours aussi
logique on nous l'interdît soi disant
parce qu'il faut pas remuer le flacon ça
devient vraiment ridicule après nous
avoir dit qu'il fallait le congelé à 80
degrés alors qu'il n'est pas content des
80 degrés dans aucun centre de
vaccination donc voilà si on pouvait
trouver un tout petit peu de logique
dans la vaccination se dépêcher vacciner
nos patients ce serait vraiment ce qu'il
ya de mieux et bien bon courage merci
bertrand le grand merci à vous d'avoir
été en direct avec nous donc quelques
instants restez avec nous nous parlerons
du retour de l'économie à son niveau pré
coville est il possible dès le printemps
2022 jacques sapir tentera d'y répondre
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h38 bienvenue en direct si vous nous
rejoignez vers un rebond un peu plus
fort que prévu de l'économie
c'est ce que prévoit en tout cas la
banque de france qui table désormais sur
une croissance de 5 5% cette année un
chiffre qui se rapproche des 6% attendue
par le gouvernement
dans ces conditions le retour de
l'activité à son niveau pré qu'ovide
interviendrait dès le printemps en 2022
dit la banque centrale un tel scénario
n'est t'il pas trop optimiste à l'heure
où la campagne de vaccination piétinées
alors où l'on re confine 16 départements
c'est l'objet de l'édito échos ce soir
[Musique]
un bon soir jacques alors ce scénario
rose est ce que vous y croyez
bonsoir c'est fanny m'écouter quand il
ya des chiffres la question n'est pas de
croire en les chiffes mais bien plutôt
de les analyser
alors oui on sait que la france a connu
une des chutes de production les plus
importantes pour 2020 il est tout à fait
logique que après cette chute
extrêmement importante - vie -8 3% du
pib
on assiste à un rebond important
sauf que il faut savoir aussi que
là-dessus la banque de france comme
l'insee d'ailleurs et bien un table sur
trois fait la première chose ça serait
que grosso modo le l'argent que les
français ont épargné et force contraint
et forcé sous les yeux du fait des
déconfinement et bien que cet argent
soit immédiatement un dépenser la
deuxième chose c'est que il y ait une
reprise extrêmement rapide de l'activité
chez nos proches voisins et la troisième
hypothèse c'est évidemment que la
campagne de vaccination se passe au
mieux
et bien malheureusement on voit que sur
ces trois points
eh bien on est loin d'être dans les
clous disons dans les perspectives que
tracent la banque de france moi c'est
moi qu'on puisse dire est tout d'abord
jacques pour bien
un conte plante le décor nous en sommes
nous un nom de crise sanitaire plus tard
alors un an de crise sanitaire plus tard
justement on voit bien qu'il ya eu une
chute extrêmement importante de la
production chute qui s'est largement
concentré sur le deuxième trimestre de
l'année 2020 qui lie à une reprise assez
forte au troisième trimestre mais qui
après a eu tendance à se modérer et ça
c'est à l'évidence l'impact du deuxième
confinement qui a quand même un petit
peu
si vous disais on couper les jarrets de
l'économie française on sait aussi que
l'industrie en fait elle travaille
autour de 76 % de son potentiel de
production
elle travaillait avant la crise autour
de 79 %
mais comme il y a eu une perte en
productivité qui est elle-même lié
d'ailleurs aux mesures sanitaires aux
mesures de protection que prennent les
entreprises aidées effectivement on va
se retrouver à 95 % du niveau pré crise
aujourd'hui alors j'arrête la france un
secteur de services très important ne
va-t-il pas rebondir de manière
spectaculaire
alors vous avez tout à fait raison
stéphanie effectivement l'économie
française est actuellement largement une
économie de services c'est ce qui
d'ailleurs a expliqué la contraction
extrêmement rapide qu'elle a subies et
c'est ce qui devrait normalement
impliqué un rebond très important et
vous voyez que suivant les prévisions là
il s'agit des prévisions qui ont été
collectionnés par un site de
statistiques cette histoire est bien
vous voyez que la france au devrait
avoir en 2021
un des résultats qui sont meilleurs que
ceux de l'allemagne du japon de l'italie
ou du royaume uni
mais et c'est un point extrêmement
important
toutes les activités de service sont des
activités qui sont très très sensible à
la situation sanitaire
or si la situation sanitaire n'évoluent
pas comme on l'a prévu et ça ça pose
évidemment le problème de la campagne de
vaccination sa cause aussi d'ailleurs le
problème du nouveau confinement ou smir
confinement que le premier ministre a
annoncé ce soir
et bien ça aura des des impacts
extrêmement important sur toute une
série d'activités que l'on pense au
restaurant évidemment à tout ce qui est
l'hôtellerie et tout ce qui est lié au
tourisme aussi aux transports en
particulier au transport aérien
et puis au commerce et on voit bien que
la pendant un mois
tous les commerces dits non essentiels
vont être fermés et qui dit fermeture
des commerces bien évidemment moindres
je dirais moindre activité pour les
grossistes et moindre activité pour les
producteurs
donc grosso modo là encore le fait qu'on
soit une économie de services ne va pas
nécessairement nous aider et puis par
ailleurs il faut toujours rappeler
s'attend que le tourisme n'aura pas
repris
l'économie française sera handicapé
parce que le tourisme il ne faut jamais
l'oublier ça représente quand même 10 %
du pib de la france et jal vous nous
dites que ces activités sont très
sensibles la crise sanitaire
oui tout à fait il ça c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut toujours avoir en vue
c'est évidemment tous les retards qui
sont accumulés dans la campagne de
vaccination alors on voit bien
aujourd'hui que il ya des problèmes de
retards de livraison qui touche tous les
vaccins alors que ce soit pfizer moderna
astrazeneca même un vaccin qui n'est pas
encore livré comme le johnson & johnson
il est d'ores et déjà en retard et on
voit très bien qu'il sera très inférieur
aux prévisions de livraisons qui avaient
été faites mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire tout ça ça veut dire que il va
manquer un nombre considérable de
vaccins sur le mois d'avril
certainement eu millions de doses la
campagne vaccinale ne va pas pouvoir
même en mettant les choses au mieux
avancé à la vitesse que l'on avait prévu
donc au lieu d'avoir vacciné grosso modo
les 70% de la population ce qui serait
nécessaire pour que nous soyons à
l'immunité vaccinale au lieu d'avoir
vacciné c'est 70% de la population fin
août début septembre ce qui était prévu
nous allons être décalé très
certainement vers le mois de novembre où
le mois de décembre est donc évidemment
la reprise de l'activité économique sera
décalée d'autant meilleur jacques le
commerce extérieur dans ces conditions
ne pourrait-il pas a contribué à tirer
la croissance française vers le haut
c'est effectivement une hypothèse qui a
été émise est tout à fait raison
stéphanie sauf que là encore il faut
bien regarder les choses
en réalité le commerce extérieur de la
france
ils se dégradent il avait commencé à se
dégrader un petit peu avant la crise et
puis avec la crise il s'est dégradée de
manière extrêmement importante pourquoi
il ya l'économie française perd en
compétitivité
il ya là trois phénomènes extrêmement
important premier phénomène c'est que
nos exportations sont durement touchés
par les effets de la crise qu'est ce que
la france export ben elle exporte en
particulier du matériel de transport des
avions a cédé ou en tous les cas des des
pièces qui sont liées à l'aéronautique
avec le groupe airbus
or c'est justement l'un des secteurs qui
a le plus souffert de la crise sanitaire
par contre nous importons beaucoup et
presque la totalité de nos produits
sanitaire des médicaments bon donc là il
y a eu une demande beaucoup plus fort
pour les importations donc déjà ces deux
phénomènes ont largement contribué à
déséquilibrer notre balance commerciale
et puis il ya un troisième phénomène qui
est important c'est ce dont j'ai parlé
c'est la baisse de productivité à
laquelle on assiste dans l'industrie
française hors baisse de productivité
qui s'explique parfaitement si vous
voulez c'est tout simplement la
conséquence des mesures de sécurité
sanitaire qui ont été prises mais cette
baisse de la productivité elle
mais d'une certaine manière en
difficulté par rapport à nos concurrents
internationaux
et c'est pour toutes ces raisons que en
réalité la balance commerciale elle va
plutôt être un frein à la croissance
qu'un accélérateur à la croissance et le
met un matelas des parents que les
français se sont constitués en 2020 on
en parle régulièrement et on parle même
de 110 milliards de
d'euros oui tout à fait vous avez tout à
fait raison
stéphanie c'était au tour de 110
milliards d'euros à la fin de l'année
dernière donc et on estime qu'il devrait
atteindre les 165 milliards d'euros à la
fin de cette année alors oui évidemment
c'est une somme considérable et on voit
bien qu'elle est je dirais le souhait de
la banque de france ça serait que les
français réinjecte cet argent dans
l'économie française
sauf qu'il faut savoir quand même deux
choses c'est que cette masse d'argent
qui est quand même très importante elle
a été épargnée
grosso modo par les 25 % des ménages les
plus riches en même temps que des
ménages à croix c'est très fortement
leur est pas les 25 % des ménages les
plus pauvres eux d épargne et ils
réduisaient leur est pas or et ça c'est
quelque chose que tous les économistes
et tous les statisticiens savent très
bien ce ne sont pas les gens qui ont les
revenus les plus élevés qui consomment
le plus
en proportion de leur revenu je parle
pas en chiffres absolus
je parle en proportion de leurs revenus
et donc si on attend des 25 % les plus
riches qu'ils réinjecte dans la
consommation à la totalité de leur
épargne là on fait une très très grosse
erreur
et puis à une deuxième raison c'est que
c'était pas bien sûr elle a été au
départ une épargne forcée
c'est tout ce qui n'a pas pu être
dépensés du fait des confinement mais
désormais parce que les français sont
inquiets quant à l'évolution de la
situation économique par rapport à la
crise économique
le risque de voir le chômage explose et
à partir de la fin du deuxième trimestre
ou du début du troisième trimestre de
cette année
et bien qu est ce qui va se passer ça
c'est qu'une partie de cet ehpad va ne
plus être une épargne je dirais forcé et
va être conservé comme une et pas de
précaution est donc là aussi bien sur
les français vont réinjecter une partie
de cette épargne dans l'économie mais
espérait que les 80%
où les 70% ne s'était pas retrouve
immédiatement le chemin de l'économie
cela me semble une hypothèse extrêmement
irréaliste merci jacques pour conclure
pardon elle c'est à dire que vous avez
des doutes sur une bonne surprise à
venir du côté de la croissance française
oui oui oui c'est fanny c'est évident
d'ailleurs je dois dire que la banque de
france a elle aussi des doutes parce que
quand on lit attentivement la nasa on
voit que ils ont prévu aussi un scénario
noir un scénario dit défavorable qui
nous donnerait uniquement une croissance
de l'ordre de 3% cette année
oui j'ai des doutes parce que je le
répète les les hypothèses de très belles
reprises pour 2021 sont fondés sur trois
hypothèses que la campagne vaccinale
fonctionne bien
ce qui n'est pas le cas que la reprise
soit extrêmement importante chez nos
voisins et qu'elle tire l'économie
française vers le haut ça ne sera pas le
cas et en fait que la totalité ou disons
que les 80 % de l'épargné accumulée ce
réinjecte dans l'économie française
et là dessus on peut avoir de très gros
doutes donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle je crains malgré tout que on se
situe plutôt du côté du scénario
qualifié de sévère ou disons du scénario
le plus pessimiste de la banque de
france que du côté des annonces qui ont
été faites actuellement c'est à dire une
croissance de 5 et demi à 5 9%
merci jacques et à la semaine prochaine
le patron des députés la raim christophe
castaner dénonce un clientélisme
indigéniste au coeur de la polémique
le syndicat étudiant de l'unef mais
surtout l'interview l'éveil de la
présidente mélanie luce sur europe 1
expliquant et que des réunions non
mixtes s'y tenait avec des
rassemblements interdits aux blancs
plusieurs élus de droite et d'ultra
droite ont eux demandé la dissolution de
l'association étudiante existant depuis
1907 le président du groupe l air au
sénat bruno retailleau souhaite lui que
la présidente de ce syndicat étudiant
soient poursuivis en justice
et pour en parler nous sommes avec jack
smith délégué national de l'uni bonsoir
jacquin smith merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france du clientélisme
indigéniste selon christophe castaner
vous êtes d'accord avec cette
appellation
la première chose à dire sur cette
affaire c'est que on a l'impression que
toute la classe politique et la classe
médiatique aussi d'ailleurs se
rencontrent juste maintenant de l'islamo
gauchisme du racialisme delà du racisme
anti-blanc de ce syndicat toutes ces
choses que je viens d'énumérer lui nino
on le dénonce en fait depuis des années
on combat sur le terrain depuis plus de
plus de 50 ans et donc on se demande en
fait pourquoi il suffit d'une dune d'une
interview à europe 1 pour que tout le
monde s'excite sur ce sujet encore une
fois nous ça fait des années que cet
islam au gauchisme ce raciste anti-blanc
ses dérives ses gratte ségrégationniste
on les dénonce
et qu'il faut et qu'il faut les
combattre donc aujourd'hui il est clair
que cette on est on est dans cette
surprise de voir toute cette classe
politique se faire un peu leur leur coup
de buzz et leurs cool comme sur 7 sur
cette affaire il faut il faut clairement
maintenant soutient lui ni sur ce sur
tous les combats que l'on fait depuis
des années
alors vous dites ça fait des années mais
enfin des réunions exclure en les
blanc c'est quelque chose qui dure
depuis des années vous vous nous dites
où c'est un phénomène tout de même
récents et vous savez les délires de
l'unef les dérives racialiste les
dérives des colonialistes les dérives du
racisme anti blanc à l'unef
ça fait effectivement des années que ça
commence que ça a commencé par don très
récemment on a eu comme vous le savez la
sphère de grenoble ou l'unef grenoble a
volontairement afficher le nom de deux
professeurs et a appelé au lynchage de
ses professeurs il y a bien évidemment
les camps des coloniaux qui sont
organisées par ce syndicat des coloniaux
ou des tests des colonialistes les
thèses indigéniste sont sont clairement
affichées il y a des listes communes
avec les étudiants musulmans de france
qui ont déjà approuvé moult fois leur
leurs accointances avec l'islamisme
radical
il y avait les réactions de nombreux des
responsables nationaux et locaux
d'ailleurs de l'unef
après l'émoi qu'a pu susciter le
lincendie de notre dame de paris où je
cite les mois que susciter cette cet
incendie était qualifié de délire de
petits blancs par des responsables de
l'unef
donc vous savez la dérive de l'unef
aujourd'hui eh bien ça fait des années
qu'on la dénonce et il faut bien se
rendre compte que l'unef n'est
aujourd'hui plus du tout représentatif
du monde étudiant et on se donne on se
demande encore une fois pourquoi le
ministère pense encore aujourd'hui
qu'ils peuvent s'appuyer sur une
organisation comme l'unef pour
représenter les étudiants et donc j'y
viens aux subventions publiques on se
demande comment le ministère peut encore
donner des centaines de milliers d'euros
par an à une organisation qui a prouvé
qu'il le prouve aujourd'hui encore qu'il
qu'ils affichent tout simplement tout
les toutes les valeurs anti france
aujourd'hui clairement certains
demanderont poursuivre en justice la
présidente de l'unef parce que c'est
prendre le problème par le bon bout est
ce que c'est comme ça justement qu'on va
faire taire ce phénomène aujourd'hui ce
que l'uni de manse demande ces deux
choses principales premièrement c'est
tout simplement l'arrêt immédiat des
subventions publiques à cette
organisation encore une fois anti france
à cette organisation racialiste et à
cette organisation qui n'est plus du
tout dans les valeurs qui font notre
pays et les valeurs qui font l'occident
et puis deuxièmement c'est aussi où vous
souvenez frédéric vidal mais nice dans
l'enseignement supérieur qui a demandé
une enquête sur l'islamo gauchisme
on s'était bien évidemment réjoui
qu'elle utilise ce terme puisque c'est
une réalité contrairement à ce que dit
le cnrs contre ce contrairement à ce que
dit la conférence des présidents
d'université qui sont tous peut même
gangréné par cette idéologie de l'islamo
gauchisme et bien on demande que sonne
ça que ce ne soit plus des mots mais des
actes et donc qu'il y ait une enquête
indépendante sur ces recherches sur
l'intersexualité sur le racialisme sort
encore une fois tout ce qui fait la
haine anti blanc est donc aujourd'hui
c'est l'arrêt immédiat des subventions
publiques à cette organisation anti
france qui prône clairement le racisme
anti blanc et une accointance et la
promotion tout simplement d'un islam
politique
et puis deuxièmement une enquête aussi
sur toutes ces recherches qui prouve en
fait un gant grainage du monde de
l'université que ça soit bien évidemment
dans le syndicalisme étudiant mais aussi
aux plus hautes sphères
quand je vous ai dit les conférence des
présidents d'université et le cnrs lui
même est gangréné en son sein par une
part par cette idéologie donc
aujourd'hui encore une fois quand on
voit la classe politico-médiatique qui
se réveille et bien on leur demande tout
simplement de se rendre compte que nous
à l'uni ça fait des années ça fait plus
de cinquante ans qu'on existe a fait
plus de 50 ans que sur les terrains on
combat cette organisation est que ça
fait des années que ces réunions non
mixtes où les blancs ou les où les
hommes sont interdites
on les combat aussi et qu'il faut
maintenant soutenir lui ni lui ni est le
fer de lance de l'opposition à l'unef
lui n'y est le fer de lance de
l'opposition à toutes ces idéologies
mortifère qui gangrène nos universités
et qu'il faut soutenir notre combat
maintenant très clair non merci jacques
ruiz d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
arte france et dans le reste
née il ya cinq ans jour pour jour le 18
mars 2016 l'union européenne et la
turquie paraphé un accord controversé
pour stopper le flux important de
migrants
cinq années plus tard le nombre
d'arrivées a drastiquement baissé dans
le même temps et les relations entre les
deux camps sont loin d'être au beau fixe
lieu et la turquie s'accusent
mutuellement de ne pas respecter leurs
obligations quentin moncler avec florian
lambert un accord aux résultats probants
mais qui tend les relations gréco
turques depuis sa signature après la
crise migratoire de 2015 le nombre
d'arrivées de migrants en grèce a chuté
de façon spectaculaire en 2020 dix mille
personnes ont traversé la mer egée ces 8
146 mille de moins qu'en 2015
en contrepartie l'europe s'était engagé
à verser deux tranches de 3 milliards
d'euros pour aider la turquie à
accueillir ces réfugiés
pour sa part la turquie souhaite
renégocier le montant des aides
financières et les délais de versement
elle estime ce pacte aujourd'hui caduque
nous sommes le pays qui accueille le
plus de réfugiés au monde avec notamment
3 27 millions de syriens
cela nous a coûté plus de 40 milliards
d'euros une somme à comparer avec des 6
milliards d'euros d' aide européenne
promise dans la corde 2016 dont
pratiquement la moitié n'a pas encore
été dépensés
il faut un partage équitable du fardeau
entre la turquie et le reste de l'europe
nous sommes convaincus que le
renouvellement de l'accord du 18 mars
2016 est impératif est dans l'intérêt de
tous de son côté la grèce appelle la
turquie à reprendre 1450 migrants
actuellement sur son sol le ministre
grec en charge des questions migratoires
et de l'asile insiste sur l'importance
d'une application convenable de l'accord
signé le 18 mars 2016 les états en
première ligne doivent à la fois
protéger leurs frontières mené les
procédures d'asile procéder au retour et
intégrer ceux qui ont droit à la
protection internationale
clairement nous ne pouvons pas faire
tout cela nous ne pouvons pas avoir à
nouveau un million d'arrivées en europe
comme en 2015
il est déterminant de renforcer les
relations avec les pays d'origine et les
pays de transit
du côté européen josep borrell a tenu à
rappeler l'importance des efforts de
chaque partie pour garantir et prolonger
la réussite de cet accord entre la grèce
et la turquie
nous devons travailler pour une
migration sur juste et régulière nous
devons mettre en place des mesures
incitatives pour que les pays tiers
accepte les personnes qui doivent
retourner dans leur pays et pour créer
un flux de migration régulière qui
permet aux personnes de voyager sans
avoir à risquer leur vie
le sommet européen qui aura lieu les 25
et 26 mars prochain sera consacré à la
relation entre l'union européenne et la
turquie
ursula von der leyen et charles michel
doivent s'entretenir en visioconférence
ce vendredi avec les chefs tayyip
erdogan et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
point complet sur l'actualité dans
quelques minutes avec fierté sa vie et
vernon
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui ait des candidats